today's video is brought to you by keeps
the brilliant service that helps you
keep your hair look for me i started
noticing i was losing my hair in my
early 20s or more other people started
noticing eventually you know you're in a
changing room at a store and they've got
those weird mirrors and you catch the
back of your head and you're like oh god
this is happening no
but when this happened to me keeps
didn't exist it was just like well
looks like we're gonna have to go bruce
willis and shave this off except i'm not
cool like bruce willis but look good
news for you young hairy still friend if
you do catch that weird look in the
mirror and notice you're losing your
hair keeps are there for you they're an
online subscription service with doctor
recommended hair loss treatments
clinically proven stuff there's no snake
oil bs here that just ends in tears and
boldness plus it's all delivered right
to your door so it's super convenient
also super affordable about half the
price of the same thing in the pharmacy
why would you even go to the pharmacy
it's more of a hassle and it's more
expensive look keeps is easier it's
cheaper it's a win-win also this isn't
some you know boom thank you for the
business we're done thing keeps comes
with a year of unlimited messaging with
your prescribing doctor so you can ask
any questions you have hair loss stops
with keeps to get 50 off your first
order go to keeps.com biographics or
click the link in the description below
that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash biographics and now
today's video
in the last days of 1927 america was
spellbound by the drama playing out in a
cincinnati courtroom george remus the
king of the bootleggers was on trial for
his life for the murder of his wife in
broad daylight in front of witnesses by
all accounts the law had rebus dead to
rise in many ways the remus murder trial
was a culmination of everything that had
happened in his life to that point the
jewel dreamers story has it all money
crime newspaper headlines and lots and
lots of liquor at times cartoonish remus
was nevertheless deadly serious when it
came to both building and keeping his
immense fortune a fortune that
inevitably slipped through his fingers
as the illegality of his actions caught
up with him the strange thing about
george remus though is that despite
being absurdly famous 100 years ago
you've probably never even heard of him
not the real story anyway good thing
though because well
we're about to sort that out
in 1902 george remus had decided that
being a pharmacist wasn't for him the 26
year old german immigrant had gone far
in the drugstore business going from
working as a clerk in his uncle store to
owning tour themselves as well as a
wholesale drug distribution business he
was married with the young daughter and
probably could have continued a
prosperous and anonymous lifestyle in
chicago until the end of his days but
that wasn't what george wanted he wanted
the american dream the brass ring the
kind of opulent lifestyle that the
robber barons of the period were living
he wanted more so he went to law school
graduating and passing the bar in 1904.
he set up his own practice initially
specializing in labor law before
becoming one of the most famous criminal
defense attorneys in chicago he excelled
in death penalty cases high-profile
murder trials where his client's life
was on the line just like his mentor
celebrity attorney clarence darrow remus
would do whatever it took to win
including resorting to trickery in one
trial he dramatically drank from a
bottle of poison to prove it was safe
and therefore that his client had to be
innocent of course the jury had no idea
that remus had ingested the antidote
before entering the courtroom when his
charisma and bluster didn't work
sometimes rumors would challenge the
opposing council to a fistfight a common
theme
ran throughout his life remus was a
walking publicity machine he craved the
attention of newspaper reporters not
only because he thrived on being the
center of attention but because he knew
that press notoriety was a great way to
attract more clients he worked long
hours but he was well compensated for
his time and he earned 45 000 in 1919
over 12 times the national average still
he dreamed of more and he discovered an
easy way to obtain the riches he desired
when the 18th amendment to the u.s
constitution went into effect in 1920.
prohibition was perhaps the strangest
thing the united states ever did as a
nation the volstead act banned the
manufacture importation or sale of
alcoholic beverages throughout the
country the end result of a decades-long
campaign by temperance associations like
the anti-saloon league overnight a
billion dollar industry was rendered
illegal tens of thousands of jobs
disappeared and hundreds of breweries
and distilleries were forced to shut
down according to the anti-saloon league
prohibition was supposed to be the cure
for most of american society's ill but
making alcohol illegal did not make the
desire for alcohol disappear instead
those who wanted to drink would turn to
the black market which already existed
for years because of bans in individual
states that predated national
prohibition those who smuggled or sold
illegal alcohol were known as rum
runners or bootleggers and in 1920 they
were making obscene amounts of money
bringing in liquor from wherever they
could get it george remus defended many
bootleggers in federal court he was
amazed just like everyone else that no
matter how steep the fine levied by the
judge the bootleggers just shrugged and
paid and then went right back out and
started breaking the law again these
guys had more money than they knew what
to do with and they were little better
than common thugs remus figured that a
man a vision a smart businessman like
himself could go into this legal
business and make a massive fortune one
that would make his lawyers salary
looked like chump change abruptly remus
sold off all of his business interests
in chicago closed his law office and
left town he left engrossed in scandal
the newspapers had covered all the
salacious details of his extramarital
affair with imogene holmes leading to an
ugly divorce from his wife lillian what
few people knew at the time however was
that he was also running from the law
escaping a prohibition charge for trying
to sell whiskey out of warehouse in the
north side of the city remus would
eventually bribe his way out of a prison
cell in that case but in the meantime he
needed to start over somewhere else 300
miles to the south of chicago is the
city of cincinnati ohio situated on the
banks of the ohio river that forms the
border with kentucky cincinnati was a
manufacturing town home to large
companies like procter and gamble and
kroger it also had a sizable german
population the city's over-the-rhine
neighborhood was hit hard by prohibition
closing bars and breweries most
importantly for george dreams however
cincinnati gave access to the untapped
riches of kentucky's bourbon trail when
prohibition took effect the country's
distilleries were forced to shut down
but their existing supplies of spirits
weren't destroyed but kept in warehouses
guarded by federal officials 80 of the
stored whiskey in america could be found
within 300 miles of cincinnati in the
warehouses of kentucky's shuttered
bourbon distilleries if remus could get
to it he would be
a very rich man
[Music]
for his plan to work remus relied on a
rather glaring loophole in the
prohibition legislation it was still
legal to manufacture and sell alcohol if
it was for medicinal purposes in the
days before medical science had caught
up to where it is today many ailments
were treated with prescriptions of
liquor or medicines that contained large
amounts of alcohol in order to possess
medicine or alcohol all you needed was a
government certificate which was easy to
obtain if you bribed the person that was
responsible for making them the way it
worked it was relatively simple remus or
one of his associates would buy a
shuttered distillery often for pennies
on the dollar as the despondent owners
were happy to collect at least some
money on what was now apparently useless
property sometimes remus would restart
production under the guise of producing
medical grade bourbon and sometimes he
just bought the property to empty out
the storehouse of existing inventory
using his knowledge of the pharmacy
industry remus would open up drug stores
that served as a front for his bourbon
shipments most of which never made it to
the stated destination instead it was
reported missing lost or stolen when in
reality it was actually being taken to a
secret distribution point just outside
of cincinnati from there it was sold to
other bootleggers who transported it out
of town to sell it to individual
customers remus was successful for two
reasons quantity and quality his network
had access to millions of gallons of
whiskey far more than anyone else
allowing him to corner the market and
the bourbon was the good stuff because
unlike many other bootleggers remus
refused to cut his product in order to
make a bigger profit if you were lucky
all they did was water it down but if
you are unlucky the liquor you bought
might be mixed with industrial alcohol
or sterno used as a heating fuel or
something else that would be more likely
to poison you than get you drunk
prohibition newspapers were filled with
stories of people who died after
drinking tainted alcohol no such issue
with remus product in a matter of months
remus was the head of a huge enterprise
employing hundreds of workers and
serving as the primary supplier of
alcohol to the country's two largest
cities new york and chicago he
established relationships with local
gangster kingpins including arnold
rothstein in new york and johnny torrio
in chicago after torrio was shot in 1925
he retired and handed the reigns over to
his lieutenant al capone the jazz ages
most notorious criminal unlike capone
who ruled through fear ramus didn't need
to resort to violence in the name of
business ramus believed that every man
had his price and he had so much money
that he was perfectly willing to pay
that price he bribed everyone local cops
prohibition agents politicians civil
servants night watchmen farmers anyone
that he needed to his web of graft
extended all the way to washington with
tens of thousands of dollars paid to
jess smith the assistant and bag man for
attorney general harry dougherty that
didn't mean his enterprise was a
peaceful one however bootlegging was a
dangerous business after all each one of
remus's shipments was accompanied by a
car load of well-armed gunmen to fend
off would-be hijackers and his own
private army protected the primary
distribution point which quickly became
known as death valley because of what
would happen to anyone that showed up
and attempted to steal remus liquor
[Music]
george dreamers had succeeded beyond his
wildest dreams and he and his new wife
imogen were quick to take advantage of
their newfound fortune the couple lived
in a huge mansion in cincinnati's
fashionable price hill neighborhood and
dreamers did business in his own
six-story office building downtown just
like the captains of industry he modeled
himself after his home life was like a
real-life version of the great gatsby as
george and imogen filled their home with
whatever opulent thing happened to catch
their eye furniture artwork marble
statues sculptures jewelry tailored
clothing furs carpets so much stuff that
it didn't all fit in and had to be
stored in the attic they owned a fleet
of cars to take them wherever they
wanted to go and spent at least 150 000
on a luxurious indoor pool and bath
house complex in the mansion and still
he found himself with more money he
literally had more cash than things to
spend it on to go with his newfound
riches he formed an eccentric
personality that made him stand out in
both the criminal underworld and the
privileged society to which he attempted
to purchase membership he always carried
an ornate walking stick with a heavy
head good for both showcasing his
sophistication and for clubbing people
over the head when he lost his temper
with them since his business ran
primarily on cash transactions and remus
distrusted banks he was known to carry
large amounts of currency on his person
at all times to the point of it
sometimes falling out of his coat
pockets one of his most unique traits
was a tendency to refer to himself in
the third person a personality quirk
known as ilism he likes to call himself
remus especially when talking to
newspaper reporters who he spent a lot
of time with despite the clandestine
nature of his business not even remus
himself knew how much money he made or
spent since he didn't keep account books
or write anything down that would be
incriminating evidence if authorities
ever got a hold of it but it is believed
that his bourbon empire sold whiskey
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
several billion dollars in today's money
and remus got the biggest piece of that
pie since he ran the entire organization
remus was certainly one of the richest
criminals in america and one of the most
successful bootleggers perhaps in
hindsight he was a bit too successful in
washington dc the head of the
prohibition bureau mabel walker
willowbrand was fuming it seemed like
nobody was taking prohibition seriously
at least of all those charged with
enforcing the law the bureau was
understaffed underfunded overwhelmed and
riddled with corruption the scale of the
law breaking had clearly taken everyone
by surprise and the government was slow
to respond as deputy attorney general
willa brandt was the most powerful woman
in america and she still had greater
ambitions like becoming the first woman
appointed to the supreme court
prohibition enforcement had to be
improved if her political goals would be
realized what she needed was a
high-profile success something to splash
around the nation's newspapers and give
her the positive publicity that she
needed to gain credibility she had to
take down a kingpin
[Music]
in october 1921 death valley was raided
by prohibition agents despite remus
instructions his underlings left a lot
of incriminating evidence relying around
which was seized remus was arrested and
charged with violating the bolstered act
released on bond the bootlegger went
about his business with little concern
for the upcoming trial he figured that
his bribery network was extensive enough
that he would be protected from prison
he was so unworried that on new year's
eve he hosted a lavish party for 300
guests in which diamond stickmans and
cars were given away as party favors but
mabel willibrandt had her sights set on
remus she was determined to string him
up as a poster child for a cause to
showcase to america that prohibition was
working in may 1922 remus was convicted
and sentenced to two years in federal
prison at another trial later the month
he was sentenced to an additional year
in prison in ohio remus remained free
while he appealed his conviction certain
that his friends in high places would
intercede on his behalf what remus
didn't realize however was that the
administration of president warren g
harding was about to completely fall
apart harding himself is not known to
have been corrupt but the people around
him collectively known as the ohio gang
made graft an art form enriching
themselves by misusing the power of
their officers accepting bribes and
orchestrating insider deals at
government expense in 1923 a thread was
pulled and the scheme began to unravel a
senate investigation into the department
of justice was turning up unpleasant
facts about the attorney general and his
aide jess smith harding told secretary
doughty to cut his friend smith loose to
save himself despondent smith committed
suicide on may 30 1923 two months later
on august the second president harding
himself died plunging the nation into
mourning harry dougherty was ousted as
attorney general by president calvin
coolidge in 1924 at the same time remus
had run out of appeals as they had all
been rejected all of his bribes all the
assurances he'd received from public
officials all of it had come to nothing
he was incarcerated at the atlanta
federal penitentiary in january 1924
while remus was in prison his wife
imogen was left in charge of all of his
assets this suited her just fine as she
loved the opulent lifestyle that she'd
become accustomed to since 1920. she'd
dumped her first husband for remus
because she believed he could provide
her with a better quality of life and
now here she was in charge of billions
of dollars of untraceable money and
valuables it was almost too good to
resist especially once she met and fell
in love with a man named franklin dodge
jr dodge ironically enough was a
prohibition agents and not just any
prohibition agent either he had played
an instrumental part in putting george
remus in prison now is not only going to
steal remus wife but all of his money
too imagine the bootlegger surprise when
he was released from prison in september
1925 only to be hit with divorce papers
from his supposed loving wife his shock
got even worse when he arrived back in
cincinnati to discover his mansion
stripped down to the floorboards as
imogen and dodge had carried off all of
his valuables they'd spent the last two
years systematically plundering what was
left of his empire living the high life
while george rotted in prison and the
worst part was little george could do
about it especially when he ended up
back in jail in ohio from july 1926 to
april 1927 for the second conviction
after those appeals were also exhausted
all the while acrimonious divorce
proceedings dragged their way through
the court system as imogen attempted to
take george for all that he had and
george striking back alleging imogen had
participated in illegal activities as
part of his bootlegging business as well
as accusing her of adultery which was
still a prosecutable offense in those
days especially for a woman things got
increasingly ugly rumors swirled that
dodge and imogen were offering a 15 000
bounty to anyone that would kill remus
george's friends reported that he was
becoming increasingly unhinged following
dodge and imaging around and ranting
about getting revenge despite his
outward image as a gentleman remus was
known for losing his temper and lashing
out both of his wives had alleged it
struck them on multiple occasions and he
had been arrested several times for
assault things reached a breaking point
on october 6 1927. that morning george
watched from a car as his wife and
step-daughter ruth climbed into a
taxicab and headed downtown for a
meeting with imogen's attorney as the
cab drove off remus's car followed remus
chased the cab down the street running
it off the road and into the grass of
the lush eden park remus car forced the
cab to stop next to a lake and a gazebo
a popular picnic spot and play area for
cincinnati families imogen fled from the
car chased by george who caught up to
her and grabbed her remus cursed his
wife punched her in the face before
pulling a pearl handled pistol from his
coat pocket in front of dozens of
shocked onlookers remus fired a single
shot into imogen's abdomen and then fled
the scene on foot two hours later the
imaginary must died on the operating
table at the same time jaw dreamers had
turned himself in to cincinnati police
detectives and confessed to the shooting
the bourbon king
is now on the hook for murder
[Music]
remus was now in for the fight of his
life literally conviction almost
certainly meant death in ohio's electric
chair accordingly he pulled out all the
stops to try and save himself no one
could deny that he had shot and killed
his wife the evidence was overwhelming
reimus defense therefore borrowed from a
tactic he'd used over a decade earlier
when defending a man accused of wife
slaying in chicago a temporary insanity
defense his contention was that his
wife's actions had driven him literally
crazy to the point of shooting her
something he wouldn't have done if he'd
been in his right mind and therefore he
shouldn't be held responsible for his
actions that day remus acted as his own
defense attorney throughout the trial
facing off against hamilton county chief
prosecutor charles p taft ii charles was
the youngest son of william howard taft
the only man to have held both the
office of the president and of united
states chief justice of the supreme
court the sensational trial played out
in the courtroom and in the newspapers
remus utilizing his connections with
reporters to sway public opinion to his
side he put the victim on trial smearing
imogen and franklin dodge as players in
a nefarious plot to destroy him he
showed conclusive evidence that the two
of them were having an affair and that
they'd conspired to steal his money and
property he made other accusations as
well they were trying to get him locked
up deported back to germany or even
trying to kill him taft countered by
arguing that it didn't matter what
imogen did to george that didn't give
him the right to kill her he brought her
parade of alienists the 1920s tied what
we today call a psychiatrist to testify
that remus had always been sane
including on the day of the murder but
he was always fighting an uphill battle
prohibition was growing increasingly
unpopular and those who provided the
masses with bootleg liquor was seen as a
kind of folk hero the court of public
opinion was firmly on remus's side from
the start which surely had an effect on
the jury on december 20th 1927 they
found remus not guilty by reason of
temporary insanity they had deliberated
for only 19 minutes
rhema spent six months at the state
hospital for the criminally insane while
lawyers battled in the courtroom about
whether he was actually insane he was
released after the ohio supreme court
determined that he wasn't and just like
that remus was a free man well he may
have been free but the bourbon empire
that had built was gone he wasn't
completely broke but the millions had
earned had disappeared seized by
government officials or squandered by
his wife and a lover and he had no taste
to try and restart it either the bootleg
gangs had risen to power while he was in
prison and had grown increasingly
violent and were drawing more and more
negative attention to themselves he was
also too well known not only in the
media but also to prohibition agents to
escape attention for long if he tried to
do anything else illegal prohibition
ended on december 5th 1933 with the
ratification of the 21st amendment the
only constitutional amendment to repeal
an earlier one individual states
continued to ban alcohol for decades
after national prohibition ended the
last tri-state mississippi went wet in
1966. the organized crime rackets that
had sprung up around bootlegging didn't
disappear after prohibition ended they
simply transitioned into other markets
like prostitution gambling becoming
what's today simply known as the mob
george rumors lived the rest of his life
in relative obscurity dying in 1952 at
the age of 75. his story is largely
unknown eclipsed by the more well-known
story of al capone and his battle with
elliot ness and his untouchables in many
ways the jaw dreamer story perfectly
encapsulates the roaring twenties a
sudden rise to unparalleled prosperity
conspicuous consumption brutal violence
underneath a veneer of sophistication
and a sudden fall from grace losing it
all and having to start over again draw
dreamus was many things throughout his
life pharmacist lawyer convict the man
who got away with murder but for one
brief shining moment draw dreamus was
the king of the bootleggers the evil
genius of prohibition the last
alastrimus had to find out the hard way
what all of us learn sooner or later
all good things must eventually
come to an end
[Music]